hallo leute ich bin kari und nicht
beantwortet heute wieder eure fragen
davy jones
ich wusste nicht dass wir fragen stellen
dürfen
ja der wie dürft ihr die frage ist
natürlich ob sie ihren beantwortet in
diesem fall würde ich gerne fragen nach
dem wort nämlich in jeder episode wird
das wort häufig gesagt und jedesmal
wundere ich mich wie man mit diesem wort
100 zu 190 rechts 100% zurechtkommen
kann oder was dieses wort überhaupt
bedeutet danke benutzer sind dort hätte
gern fünf brötchen nämlich zwei normale
ja davy überlegen jetzt schon seit zehn
minuten ich habe deine frage erst mal
vorgelesen ohne selber die antwort zu
wissen nämlich ist tatsächlich ist
nämlich ist nämlich wirklich viel
komplizierter zu übersetzen als ich
dachte und nämlich kann nämlich mehrere
heißen auf englisch kann es heißen
aliasing partikel in particular in bed
is to say was man angeblich im
englischen nicht so oft benutzt und wir
benutzen das entweder als als grund oder
um etwas nochmal genauer zu sagen wenn
man zum beispiel sagt er hat seine
herzlich von seiner besten seite gezeigt
nämlich seine pünktlichkeit
okay das ist ein komischer satz auch im
deutschen aber man kann es übersetzen
mit bailey oder man kann es übersetzen
mit groß um nochmal also man mit diesem
nämlich vertieft man nochmal etwas und
und wiederholt noch meine aussage aber
in einer vertiefenden weise ja zum
beispiel ich kann am samstag nicht
mitkommen ich bin nämlich schon
verabredet das würde man übersetzen mit
come on saturday cristina morelli
meetings am ohr
also man betont nochmal den grund dafür
oder ich hoffe dass der urlaub gut wird
ich habe nämlich viel geld dafür bezahlt
i hope that the action is going to be
aussem karl peter lachniet also das wäre
eine und das andere ist dieses bailey
wenn man noch mal ein beispiel anführt
ich hoffe das hat irgendwie geholfen es
ist ein vielschichtiges wort ganz
wichtig wir haben ja letzte woche hatten
wir die frage mit dem rücken
da habe ich eines vorurteil des
deutschen essen rülpsen was wirklich
nicht stimmt weitergegeben weil
angeblich habe ich gehört dass chinesen
und koreaner machen
daraufhin haben sich unsere koreanischen
und chinesischen zuschauer gemeldet und
haben das vehement abgewiesen
und zwar schreibt jemand mit einem
chinesischen namen den ich nicht
aussprechen kann aber sieht die chinesen
auch also die chinesen sind auch
unhöflich wenn jemand beim essen höchst
kari sie machen einen fehler ich soll
ihnen daran erinnern was denn für einen
fehler den wir ja auch schon mal
vorgelesen haben hier in der sendung
schreibt das mit tröten beim essen in
korea ja und nein also er relativiert
schon ich selbst bin koreaner und finde
es ist in korea schon okay zurück sein
aha wenn man nur mit seinen besten
freunden oder mit seiner familie ist wo
damit ihnen dennoch auf jeden fall nicht
in einem öffentlichen raum zum beispiel
nicht in einem restaurant wo viele leute
gleichzeitig nehmen einen sind ansonsten
ist das wissen beim essen in korea auch
genau so unhöflich wie in deutschland
habe aber keine ahnung wie es in china
ist ja dann wissen wir jetzt auf jeden
fall schon mal dass sich kim unser
freund aus korea
er ist tatsächlich noch essen aber nur
mit seiner familie und seinen besten
freunden
alexejew schreibt wie geht es dir kari
ja was soll ich dazu sagen
gut geht es mir
heinz videos meimane problem with the
german ist difference between mir und
mich that really hard and wish you tube
video explaining bis techno bei der
eroberer kanal
das ist ganz einfach der woche glaube
ich gar kein ganzes video der
unterschied ist mir ist da tief und mich
ist akkusativ also es sind ja zwei
unterschiedliche worte und wie du dir
das merken kannst ist am besten guckst
du im internet welche werben mit dativ
und welche mit akkusativ gebildet werden
es gibt nämlich werben die werden immer
mit dativ gesprochen und da musst du
dann immer mehr einsetzen so wie du auch
andere substantive ins archiv setzen
muss zum beispiel geben ist immer mit
dativ ich gib mir mal die butter oder
ich gebe dir mein auto da ist das dir
und dass mir das ist da tief oder ich
gebe dem haus einen neuen anstrich dativ
und ein anderes wert zum beispiel suchen
ist immer mit akkusativ du suchst mich
schon seit zwei stunden dann hast du
mich oder ich suche dich dann musst du
mich und dich benutzen
eigentlich ganz einfach oder du musst
nur wissen welches werk mit was mit
welchem fall gebildet wird übrigens
morgen kommt auch eine neue episode wo
wir schon mal den akkusativ vorstellen
guck mal rein
er schrieb schreibt was denken die
deutschen über das militär und die
mitbestimmung im mittleren osten
unterstützt er die soldaten und haben
die deutschen auch respekt für sie sehr
gute frage agiert zu drei anmerkungen
die erste ist eine sprachliche der
mittlere osten mit dem englischen middle
east heißt im deutschen der nach osten
das ist schon mal gut zu wissen ob wir
was denken wir über das militär generell
würde ich sagen dass deutsch im
vergleich zu anderen
ländern sehr sehr kritisch sind
gegenüber dem militär und deswegen auch
respekt haben wir auf jeden fall aber
wir haben weniger also weniger ehrfurcht
so kann man sagen und es ist auch
weniger angesehen zum militär zu gehen
also diese ganze tradition zum beispiel
wie in den usa oder anderen ländern wo
man militärparaden hart und und weiteren
stay und alles total wichtig ist und
leute die man militär sind total wichtig
sind das gibt es bei uns tatsächlich
nicht das heißt aber nicht dass wir
soldaten nicht respektieren im gegenteil
im moment dass es punkt 2 haben wir
gerade eine ganz interessante debatte in
deutschland denn unsere bundeswehr ist
gar nicht so gut ausgerüstet und so
machen viele leute witze darüber dass
die gewehre nicht richtig funktionieren
dass die panzer nicht richtig
funktionieren dass weder keine
funktionierende flugzeuge haben das ist
im moment so ein bisschen die debatte
denn die bundeswehr hat tatsächlich zu
wenig geld und auch ein bisschen
vielleicht kann man das so sagen zu
wenig anerkennung und das hängt mit
unserer geschichte zusammen wir
deutschen haben ein bisschen
zwiespältiges verhältnis militär kann
man sagen wir finden es komisch wenn man
das militär zu wichtig nimmt wegen
unserer geschichte wir wollen gar nicht
so viel aufmerksamkeit für das militär
hat aber dazu geführt dass das militär
jetzt auch nicht mehr so gut
ausgestattet ist dass es wirklich
einsatzfähig ist und deswegen gibt es
die witze aber auch den anspruch und die
forderung das militär künftig besser
auszustatten
das zur aktuellen debatte über das
militär in deutschland letzte frage
kommt von stereo lens und er schreibt
ich habe eine frage wann wird janosch
als moderator von esi german erscheinen
ich bin sehr interessiert wie gut
janisch auf deutsch spricht
jannis das ist jetzt die frage der
zuschauer ich habe ja noch nicht
vorbereitet auf dieser frage ich möchte
jetzt sofort eine antwort haben
tatsächlich haben schon andere von euch
nachgefragt und die haben es war ganz
stolz dass leute ihnen gerne vor der
kamera
ich mach das so schnell wie möglich
wahrscheinlich nach namibia von namibia
schaffen wir das nicht bald weg gerne
und nach namibia sehr schnell ich habe
schon das thema und carina macht für
mich die kamera das wollen jetzt alle
wissen was willst du denn die menschen
auf der straße fragen
eine frage die zu dir passt ja genau
sie ist ja schon festgesetzt und zwar
eine ganze reihe von fragen
ich will nicht nur einmal raus ich will
regelmäßig raus und job wegnehmen oder
was das ja nicht dass er nicht das wird
zunehmen herlaufen und das wird sich an
ein bestimmtes publikum richten weil
meine ich hoffe dass meine frage so eine
mischung sein kann von von einer
philosophischen reflexion und von etwas
von den und die beiden herangehensweise
das heißt ich möchte die frage ich
möchte so ernste fragen stellen dass ich
schon dann nicht mehr ernst sind oder
nicht mehr ganz ernst beantragt
zum beispiel was ist die bedeutung vom
leben oder von deinem leben und das ist
eine frage die so hoch gegriffen ist
dass sie nur zum witzen verführt und
produziert und das hoffe ich allerdings
möchte ich dann aber auch menschen
erreichen die berufliche diese frage
nachdenken zu philosophen die gänse und
das werde ich mach's lebens demnächst
mit janosch dahmen
seid ihr gespannt weil ich zum beispiel
ob die welt existiert ist auch wie geht
auf fragen die ich mir stelle existiert
diese kaffee ist nämlich total sicher
diesen saal west auf jeden fall wir
können es nicht beweisen was schon an
sich sind usa nicht aber weiß dass oder
glaubst du dass ich glaube an einen kuss
von dir doch nicht vor der kamera
hesse tja liebe leute das war's auch
schon für diese
wache wir haben ich habe viel mehr
fragen hier auf dem zettel gehabt als
ich beantworten konnte und es war toll
und ich möchte gern noch mehr fragen
beantworten das heißt ihr müsst uns wie
der neue fragen schicken nächste woche
umso witziger umso ernster umso
trauriger ihr dürft alles fragen der
hauptsache es ist interessant schickt
mir eure fragen zu deutschland manche
auch zur deutschen sprache der band
nicht so gut drin aber grundsätzlich
beantworte ich alles danke fürs
zuschauen und bis bald
hier unten könnt ihr noch selbst
schreiben und hier könnt ihr uns auch
katrin unterstützen womit ihr uns echt
helft denn damit könnt ihr mithelfen zu
unserer community zu gehören und zum
beispiel unser studio gemeinsam zu
finanzieren
wir freuen uns wenn ihr dabei seid danke
fürs zuschauen und bis nächste woche